the black hole is one of those movies I
always heard a lot of people talk about
but not usually very favorably and after
having finally see it I can definitely
see why it's Disney's attempt at trying
to be every popular sci-fi film that's
ever come out in fact you can point
practically scene by seeing what movie
they're trying to replicate first it's
alien then it's Belle star Galactica
that's 20,000 Leagues Under the Sea
then it's Star Wars and then finally
it's 2001 the space odyssey in trying to
combine them all together you get a film
that has very little identity it's just
kind of a huge mess but at the same time
I can't say it was entirely bad there
are some good things about it a couple
maybe it starts off with an expedition
in space where they come across a craft
that apparently has been lost for years
a scientist and his robot standing on
the edge of the black hole he claims the
rest of the crew died yeah that's it and
that he's been spending his time trying
to figure out how he can go through the
black hole and come out the other end
he thinks he's finally found a way and
everybody's intrigued to see if he can
actually do it the downside is there's a
lot of mysterious things going on his
robot crew almost seems a little too
human and it's just this all-around
threatening tone where the people feel
more like prisoners than they do guess
secrets are discovered sides are
declared and it's a battle to see who
can get off the ship alive but this part
about the movie strangely enough is its
atmosphere and don't get me wrong a lot
of the effects are not very good they're
supposed to be flying around in space
but it just kind of looks like they're
standing around and the keying is really
really bad I mean look at that can you
take a guess where the real film is and
where the map painting begins yeah it's
pretty painful but it almost makes up
for it with this gigantic feeling of
dread throughout the first half
everybody knows something sneaky is
going on but they can't quite put their
finger on what it is they're just
waiting for a trigger moment to whip out
their guns and start defending
themselves but there never really seems
to be a reason to plus it has maybe one
of the scariest robots of all time
Maximillian yeah doesn't sound very
scary but whenever he's on screen all
the music stops all the sound goes dead
and you just feel this thing's presence
he even gets in a few decent kills every
once in a while
look at this see Jesus Christ for Disney
that's pretty gruesome for such a simple
design I love how uncomfortable I feel
whenever he's on screen he doesn't even
say anything it's just I don't know it's
just this presence they create aside
from that the evil scientist is pretty
good Ernest Borgnine adds a little bit
of comedy but all the other actors are
under this really weird stoic way of
acting and it just comes across as so
wooden even great actors like Robbie
McDowell and Anthony Perkins you can
sense they're trying to get a good
performance out of this but there's just
so little to work with there's a lot of
elements they throw in that don't really
seem to go anywhere either
for example this woman's telepathic it's
useless there's totally no point to it
at all she communicates with the robot
at some point but what they don't have
communicators walkie-talkies cellphones
none of that is created in the future
the ending itself is just a huge
clusterfuck
it makes us in images of Heaven and Hell
and yeah I don't know why I don't know
what it's trying to say but it's not
quite like 2001 where the vagueness is
part of the intrigue it's more like
we're obviously trying to say something
you just can't figure out what it is and
based on the rest of the film you can
tell that whatever it had to say
probably wasn't that intelligent or
interesting look at this this incredibly
fake asteroid fields going by and one
even crashes into the ship why the hell
is it going that slowly they're whizzing
by at incredible speeds before and now
it's giving time for the characters to
cross a bridge right in front of it it's
like a school crossing it just looks
ridiculous but I do give credit to the
film that it was at least trying to be a
little smarter than your average sci-fi
film
yeah Star Wars in 2001 were big hits and
everybody was trying to copy them and so
is this film but a lot of it's very
dialogue focus not much action not much
running around I guess I kind of like
the fact that at least made an attempt
to be smarter it just didn't seem to pay
off so yeah I guess like what a lot of
people say it's not a very
film even by the so bad it's good
standards it's still not very good but I
am glad I saw few of those scenes that
created some pretty decent atmosphere
even if it was really fake looking
definitely not one of Disney's best you
can probably just give it a pass so a
lot of people have been requesting
something wicked this way comes which is
interesting because when the film came
out it was a major bomb it didn't even
make half of its money back and truth be
told I never even heard of it until I
was like maybe in the ninth grade
remember it's being shown in my schools
and understanding of Ray Bradbury's work
and all the kids were so excited
Something Wicked This Way Comes oh I
love that movie I was kind of wondering
how I missed it as I thought I saw the
really dark eighties kids films that
came out around that time I say this to
point out that this is not a film I grew
up with so I'm not really gonna let the
nostalgia factor get in the way but that
doesn't necessarily make it a bad film I
just don't think I love it like
everybody else loves it
the movie centers around two boys one
named Will Holloway and the other named
get this Jim nightshade God how does
Brad berry find these incredible names
they're often seen around Will's father
who's an old librarian and they spend
most their time just getting into
trouble all sorts of difficult boy stuff
but then one night a carnival arrives I
mean literally one night it's all put
together in a matter of just a few
minutes and this has been put together
by dr. dark played by Jonathan Pryce he
welcomes people to the carnival but the
boys figure out that slowly but surely
it seems to be sucking away people's
souls
apparently draining their life force and
messing with their actual age of course
nobody believes the boys story so it's
up to them to figure out how to stop
this evil monster I get the feeling even
if I saw this as a little kid I wouldn't
find it very scary but it is pretty
creative the atmosphere on characters
especially make up for the fact that the
story itself is not phenomenally
interesting or
these kind of slow-moving they kind of
go through the typical run-of-the-mill
stuff of people not believing them
trying to convince those that will
believe them boiling the charismatic
diabolical Villa and all that good stuff
it's not a film that screams exciting or
super creepy it's more of a laid-back
kind of elegant film it's hard to
explain it's like the creepy stuff
doesn't come out at you and say boo
it's more building up this environment
that slowly is trying to get you without
you necessarily even knowing it and that
the foreground of that is Jonathan Pryce
who is just perfect as the villain he
never goes quite to over-the-top but at
the same time he's just so graceful and
loving of what he does just look at that
outfit you can tell he wears that suit
with such incredible charisma but at the
same time he's never too charming that
he's not scary a key can still look at
him and know he's the bad guy I really
like wills father in this too you just
get the feeling he's trying to make ends
meet be a good person and just do what
needs to be done but at the same time
life is trying to wear on him and he
just doesn't know what to believe in
anymore this of course is a great
contrast for the kids who see all sorts
of fantastic things but have a hard time
making the adult of the world realise it
a part of me does wish it would go a
little further with its creepy imagery
and disturbing thoughts why not get a
few more monsters or go a little bit
edgier I think that's why people still
talk about films like return to Oz and
Sleepy Hollow and so forth because they
did take risks and while this one
certainly has a lot of atmosphere it
doesn't really try anything that
different okay I don't be Monster Squad
style violence but something to make it
stand out a little bit more but then
again maybe you could argue that's a
part of its charm it's not an
in-your-face movie it's not a very
obvious monster film the journey and the
build-up and the suspense maybe is what
the star is supposed to be it is a kid's
film after all and after hearing all the
people that talk about and remember it I
guess it did leave a bigger impact than
I imagined it probably would it's a good
film I just don't think it's great I
think I get more sucked into the foggy
shadows that I do the actual characters
or story but they still suck me in
enough to want to know what's gonna
happen
if you're looking for one of those
classic intense 80s kids films are super
dark and super shocking that's probably
isn't it for you well if you're looking
for something to just put on that has a
lot of atmosphere and a bit of a creepy
vibe this might be more up your alley
think something like are you afraid of
the dark except a little smarter and
more elegant check it out next Halloween
and see for yourself growing up in the
80s and 90s we had a lot of various
specials that always acted like they
were gonna scare us
Weah Tales from the Crypt are you afraid
of the dark goosebumps all sorts of
various shows that kept explaining how
they were gonna scare the crap out of us
and don't get me wrong I like these
shows I think they're really creative
but there's always one problem to me
they were never scary evil mouths a kid
I was saying to myself where's the scary
stuff where's the stuff that's gonna
fuel my nightmares where's the stuff
that's gonna keep me up watch her in the
woods
is that movie yes it's Disney and yes
it's technically family-friendly but it
works like any great scary horror film a
lot of atmosphere a lot of buildup a lot
of mystery a lot of great shots and a
lot of creepy as well as clever imagery
the story is a family is looking in
Britain for a new house to move into
they of course find a big creepy place
that of course has this terrible
backstory an uncomfortable landlord and
all sorts of supernatural things
happening around it both the daughters
in the family seem to have strange
things happening to them the youngest is
almost being taken over like a puppet
and the older has a tendency to feel the
presence of people that were once there
before or just feel all sorts of
uncomfortable things slowly but surely
the truth about the disappearance of a
certain girl named Karen comes to light
and the daughters are trying to figure
out if it's the ghost of Karen that's
trying to get in contact with them or
something else what I like about this
film is that there's very few things
that actually separate it from a kid
scary film and a regular scary film in
fact I think this film has a lot more
atmosphere and scares than most scary
films
the only difference is there's no gore
murdering or swear words in it as well
as the pacing is a little quicker than
that of a usual scary movie but again
they want to keep the kids attention but
apart from that they treated pretty
adult notice how many quiet moments are
in this yeah remember that you could
have family films that had quiet moments
there didn't always need to be a ton of
music or talking this is called
establishing mood and it's dunked right
here the shots are also great I
absolutely love how they make these
woods both beautiful and creepy at the
same time the cinematography
surprisingly kind of has an evil dead
feel to it obviously not as over-the-top
but just as clever with its setups my
favorite shot is right in the opening
it's just a car pulling into the place
well that's no biggie no well that shot
was kind of sloppily done wait a minute
why are we still rolling oh my god this
is a point of view shot
what's watching them what's going on
okay it's not a big scare but at the
same time it kind of catches you off
your guard it's setting up something you
didn't know what's being set up and
that's what a good scary film should do
the fine thing too is that there's a lot
of point view shots in this film but
just when you're about to get sick of
them they do something new with it for
example here's a shot of her just going
through the woods yeah yeah something's
watching her we've seen that a million
times but then at some point she goes
inside and wait a minute it's still out
there why would they show this shot if
something wasn't gonna happen
and it does and it was properly built up
and properly delivered and just we think
a shot like that can't make you
uncomfortable again there's another
scene where she's being followed well
okay again we've seen that a million
times but wait a minute now it's inside
we didn't know it could go inside every
time we've seen it it's always been
outside every time they do something
with a point of view shot they add
something new to put you in a new state
of uncomfortableness it doesn't downplay
anything because it's also gonna be
shown to kids no it wants to scare the
kids because that's why you're seeing a
scary movie I always hate it when those
other shows had to clean it up and not
make it too creepy this goes all out
there and tries to scare you without
actually psychologically harming you
kids can be drawn in to smart things and
scary films can be smart the only
downside I have of this film is that the
acting from the main character is not
very good it's really hokey and awkward
and kind of reminds me of the girlfriend
from airplane but I did see something in
the mist at the pond that's why I fell
in but even then I don't mind too much
because the whole film has such a
strange feel to it that even the acting
in its weirdness actually kind of blends
in the whole film style is so uniquely
its own that you kind of get used to it
and maybe a cat's to the weird feeling
that you have throughout the entire
movie
I don't want give away too much as part
of the fund is being scared and
surprised by it but I will say it's very
well done I kind of don't know why more
people aren't talking about it I mean
it's a legit scary film from Disney how
often does that happen
I mean we got scary moments from other
films that scare us because we're kids
and yeah some of them go really far but
this is actually intending throughout
the majority of the film to scare you
and it's actually effective our scary
movie fans just put off that the Disney
logo is in front of it our Disney fans
put off that's a little too dark and not
as obvious for kids I don't know but it
definitely deserves a lot more attention
okay I don't think it's gonna send
anyone out running and screaming but at
the same time it just creates this mood
in this environment that just feels
drange and dark and creepy and Pownall
personally I just love it I wish more
scary films aimed at kids tried this
hard Alano if it's a censorship issue or
if people are just too afraid to push
the limit but there's got to be more
movies like this I can tell you for
certain I found a new film to watch
every Halloween the atmosphere the
environment the story the characters the
scares I'm just in love with this film
it's definitely worth checking out with
the lights off when you're all alone and
you feel like somebody's watching you
I have never seen a film that looks like
Dick Tracy and I know a lot of people
say that although this imagery isn't
like anything you've ever seen in blah
blah blah but it's really true I can't
think of any other movie that looks like
this this might be the most ambitious
Lee visual spectacle I've seen in years
it's crazy the colors that designs the
costumes the makeup it's totally insane
which is why it really sucks that I
can't remember a single friggin thing
about it is it that the visuals were so
good it distracted from the rest of the
story or is it that the story wasn't
really that hot to begin with Dick Tracy
based on the famous newspaper comic
strip is the yellow trench coat wearing
cop played by Warren Beatty who's trying
to take down the massive crime in his
fair city his arch-nemesis big boy
played by Al Pacino is the yelling and
screaming mob gangster who constantly
wants to put him out of his way he comes
across a kid simply named kid a singer
named breathless Mahoney played by
Madonna and all sorts of weird and
literally colorful characters that
constantly want to kill it there's
flat-top babyface the blank they only
get crazier and crazier okay so the
basic story is good guys versus bad guy
has cute kid sidekick has a femme fatale
all the classic stuff you usually see in
a lot of film noir is and so on that
part is easy to follow what's not easy
to follow it's the steps they're taking
to create this formula there's a lot of
talk of business a lot of talk of fraud
a lot of talk a strategy a lot of talk
of planning a lot of talk of breaking in
busting a person and yeah we see it
happen but what do we really know about
these people
aside from Al Pacino who's really
yucking it up as the bad guy
there's nothing memorable about these
characters Warren Beatty is a tough cop
and that's about it
Madonna is the hot singer and that's
about it the wisecracking kids a
wisecracking kid and that's about it you
get where I'm going with this
hearing them talk is not very riveting
and it's
we being distracted by how incredible
the backgrounds are when the action
finally does start it looks pretty cool
but what do I care if any of these
people get axed off a part of me kind of
respects that they're trying to take
such a cartoon Elise illy looking film
so seriously but on the other hand I
just wish it could have been more
interesting I remember in the credits
that said that Dick Van Dyke was in this
movie Dick Van Dyke where the hell was
he oh there he is
god I didn't even notice him he's in and
out of the film so fast that he's barely
even worth the credit if Dick Van Dyke
dick then frickin die can't leave an
impact on you in a movie you know
there's got to be something wrong with
it
on top of that there's a lot of scenes
in the movie they're just downright
gruesome especially for a Disney film
early on they take this one gangster
down by tying him up putting him in a
box covering him in when cement and then
throwing him in the river all while he's
crying and sobbing the whole time that's
pretty intense don't get me
wrong I like a little dark and gritty in
Disney films but it's like something
right out of a nightmare I guess to the
film's credit it's not that it's really
bad or annoying it's just kind of dull
like I said I can barely remember what
actually happened in this movie I just
remember it looked beautiful while it
was happening with that said yeah it is
friggin unbelievable to look at I mean
who would dressed this way who would
design their buildings this way who
would choose these colors who would have
faces this bizarrely weird nobody would
its obviously taking the idea of
adapting the comic strip which was very
bright colorful and over-the-top to a
whole new level it's definitely in its
own unique world one where the
backgrounds don't even have to look that
convincing I mean look at this this is
so obviously a matte painting they're
not even trying to hide the brushstrokes
but that's just part of the style
it all looks phony but in the same way
that a puppeteer holding a puppet you
know is phony but you don't care it's
just so well done that you enjoy every
second of it so I'm kind of torn on the
movie on the one hand I'm glad I saw it
if for any other reason just to see it
but on the other hand
yeah why couldn't they make the story
more interesting like lonely flesh out
the characters more why couldn't they be
a lot more fun like I said Pacino's
great but everyone else is just so
phoned in and standard just because they
looked as dink doesn't mean they act
distinct
I remember the makeup in the layout much
more they remember anything else in this
bill that's really a shame if this
didn't have a memorable story and
characters maybe it could be like one of
the great film memoirs a film that plays
to incredibly heavy shadows but also
somehow incredibly heavy colors it could
have been sort of this one-of-a-kind
masterpiece but as is is really just a
style over substance movie if you want
to see the style and you just enjoy
watching people and trench coats and
fedora hats punch each other and shoot
then you'll at least be glad that you
saw it but if none of that does it for
you it then I'm sad to say this is a
very unfortunate skip
[Music]
it's the holiday classic The Nightmare
Before Christmas boy talk about a film
that only did okay at the box office but
just exploded in cult merchandise every
year around Halloween you see this stuff
advertised and now every year around
Christmas you see it advertised as well
somewhere the appreciation of this film
just went through the roof and now
everybody loves to draw the characters
they love to sing the songs it's so
iconic but once again I almost feel like
that can backfire and build it up too
much for audiences that might be
expecting something else in a sense
that's kind of what I went through when
I first saw it and I saw when it first
came out he was advertised on TV Tim
Burton's name was plastered all over it
and it came out around the same time
that movies like Aladdin Lion King and
so many other anime groundbreakers came
out so with that said I thought there
would probably be a few more adult jokes
thrown in there you know like what they
do with rabble Liam's improvising and so
on but that's not the kind of movie it
is it's more a warped version of those
stop-motion Christmas specials that you
see every year except dragged out to an
hour and a half it seems all the
holidays are given their own land
Halloween town Christmas town and all
that kind of stuff the leader of
Halloween Jack Skellington is funnily
getting tired of his holiday a lots to
try something new
thus he accidentally stumbles across the
Christmas holiday and decides he wants
to take it for his own showing the
people of Halloween what he's discovered
and even kidnapping Santa Claus himself
Jack decides he's gonna transform a
Merry Christmas into a scary Christmas
instead of bringing treats and toys he's
gonna bring creeps and scares ultimately
resulting in a disaster as catastrophe
the movie has a lot going for it first
of all the story is wonderful it's so
simple and setup and yet allows for so
much creativity it's bizarrely very easy
to explain and even easier to grasp the
visuals of course being a Tim Burton
production are gonna be wonderful and
not only that the music's gonna be
spectacular this is the first time in
years Danny Elfman has been allowed to
write songs again and
man do they knock it out of the park you
know these songs this is Halloween
what's this what's this making Christmas
the list goes on
Elfman himself does the singing voice of
Jack and he adds so much character to it
this whole film is practically his movie
but what people might be turned off by
especially those who have had at hype
dub is that it is maybe a little too
simple at least for what people might be
expecting the movie doesn't have a lot
of inside jokes are super clever writing
it's sort of very bare bone because of
this it doesn't allow for a ton of
character or a ton of surprises but
that's not really the focus it's
supposed to operate more like a very
basic fairy tale like a book you'd read
to your little kid in fact help it was
originally a book and in rhyme to some
might have a problem with this but it's
understandable
they could have updated it a little bit
more they could have made the characters
a bit more interesting but for a lot of
people the simplicity is what draws them
to it it's a timeless story that can be
told to anyone and anyone can grasp it
very quickly it's similar to something
like the boy who cried wolf you don't
need to know the boy's backstory you
don't need to know his character you
just need to know the very simple layout
now is that good for an hour and a half
movie somewhat debate no me personally I
think there's enough creativity with the
songs the atmospheres the designs and
even the very basic characteristics that
I think it works ok I'd be lying if I
said this was one of my absolute
favorites in Burton films I mean it's
good and I really like it and I can hear
those songs over and over but it's not
something I really watch because the
characters are so deep or the emotions
are so rich i watch something like
Batman or Edward Scissorhands for that
Nightmare Before Christmas is just a
very simple yet still very clever and
creative kids story and like I said the
simplicity is what helps it sell and
what helps it stay around for so long I
think that's one of the reasons it
wasn't a monster hit when it came out
but people still seem to talk about it
and buy merchandise from it all the time
they appreciate the basicness of it in
the same way they appreciate the
basicness of Santa Claus and can
immediately connect it to the holiday or
in this case two holidays
I say I appreciate it more than I like
it but I do still enjoy putting it on
every once in a while the songs the
imagery the creativity than just a
little too strong for me to resist it's
a simple film that knew just how much to
deliver and how much to let you take
away from it and it doesn't look like
it'll be leaving anytime soon a lot of
times when people try to take a
successful TV show and make a movie out
of it the number one complaint is that
it just seems like a longer version of
an episode but with duck tales it kind
of makes sense because every episode was
kind of like a mini movie so why not
make an actual movie out of it in this
case it definitely pays off and it's
kind of a shame it doesn't get more
attention than it deserves it's funny
because this came out near the same time
as the rescuers down under another
adventurous Disney film that doesn't get
enough attention it has all the great
animation the characters you remember a
lot of great action a few good jokes
it's an enjoyable family film scrooge
mcduck and the gang are on the search
for the treasure of collie Baba get it
but their tour guide named is Jean is
working for an evil sorcerer named
Merlin played by Christopher Lloyd he
knows that the real treasure of collie
Baba lies in this magic lamp and that
with his magic talisman that can turn
him into any animal can combine it with
the lamp to get unlimited wishes the
lay-up however falls out of his hands
and instead into the hands of Huey Dewey
Louie and webby who discovered the crazy
genie inside played by Rick Taylor
he's Amy and goofy of course and
befriends the kids very quickly once
Scrooge discovers say he uses it of
course for greedy means and while being
chased down by the evil sorcerer he
discovers what truly matters and blah
blah blah action learning a lesson all
that good stuff okay so there's no
groundbreaking morals there to be
learned here but that's not what duck
tales was all about in fact duck tales
wasn't even as much about action as it
was adventure and this is a really
enjoyable adventure
I feel like all the characters we've
grown to love get the proper amount of
screen time that they deserve
Christopher Lloyd is menacing of course
as the villain and the tailor is an
adequate genie I do feel bad because
shortly after a much funnier Disney
genie would pop about that nobody could
really compete with but for something
that's more focused on kids and family
and not really adult jokes I think he
works okay it's fine cuz the animator on
the show was already pretty impressive
so they had to up it even more from the
movie and it really looks good the only
thing that might raise a few eyebrows is
the character of Dijon I don't know is
this an offensive character now back
then nobody thought twice about but
nowadays with people's sensitivities I'm
not sure this could be taken the wrong
way or not I mean he does have a thick
accent and he is a thief I personally
never thought they were saying anything
about an entire race but maybe that's
why it never got such a major DVD
release oh no he's fine by me but some
people might take it a different way
like I said before it's just one big
duck tails episode but we all really
like the duck tails episodes and what
they had to give us and here it is on a
grand scale I'd be lying if I said it
was as good as the original few episodes
that were tied together in the beginning
but hey we're doing a movie now and you
gotta play by movie rules and for
Playboy movie rules I think this film
does really well and it's entertaining
and it's engaging does they have a ton
of adult stuff not especially I'd say
it's more family-oriented but there's
nothing wrong with that it's done well
it's done creatively and it's a whole
lot of fun so if you like the show
growing up or you're a big fan of
adventure this is definitely one to
check out
[Music]
[Applause]
well if you saw my original Disney
semper review of 101 Dalmatians you
probably won't be that shocked that I
think pretty much the same thing about
the live-action one which is fine
because in many respects it is exactly
like the original and yet completely
different the story is exactly the same
the characters are exactly the same the
setting is exactly the same but there is
however one major difference the dogs
don't talk a lot of people I remember
when this was coming out we're really
angry and shocked at that oh my god how
can the dogs not talk they talked in the
original holy smokes and what's it all
about - well very much like the anime
one is just a movie about watching
puppies and if you like to watch puppies
you'll like this film fine the story
centers around a male Dalmatian and his
owner played by Jeff Daniels who has his
eye on a female Dalmatian who has a
pretty attractive owner as well of
course both the dogs and the humans meet
up and they decide to get together over
time they get married and eventually the
female dog gets pregnant giving birth to
15 adorable puppies but an evil villain
incredible play by Glenn Close wants to
buy the puppies so she can turn them
into fur coats when the owners tell her
that they're not for sale she hires two
henchmen one of them played by Hugh
Laurie to kidnap the puppies and add
them to her collection that's right a
collection for she plans to make tons of
fur coat out of tons of puppies 99 to be
exact when the parents as well as other
animals catch word Thor races on to see
if they can save the puppies before
they're turned into fashion statements
on the one hand I say to myself this is
a completely pointless movie to exist
did this really demand to be brought to
the live-action cinema but with that
said if you had to bring it to
live-action cinema I actually think it's
pretty reasonably done I really applaud
the fact that they don't have them talk
not only was the technology not up to it
back then I mean they could move the
lifts but they look at it creepy but the
movie knows exactly what the people want
they just want to see cute dogs and if
they start talking it would just be
really weird and distracting thus we had
to rely on the charm of the human
characters which for the most part hold
up for
well I mean for such bit parts that have
little to on they actually got some
really good actors to bring into life
the romantic couple are good the
henchmen are good and yeah let's talk
about Glenn Close is corral Deville on
the one hand I should be really angry at
this performance because yeah Cruella
Deville is an over-the-top character but
this is really over the top
Carrillo was an angry bitter woman this
is just a laughing lunatic she's more
like a 60s Batman villain than she is a
Disney villain and God doesn't that
sound weird to say she's making animated
Disney villains look subtle however with
that said she just cracks me the up
it's kind of like a female Tim Curry or
Christopher Walken there's just no doubt
that she's doing whatever the hell she
wants I mean look at her she's totally
off her rocker if we make this code it
would be as if I were wearing your dog
[Laughter]
maybe the way to look at it is not that
she absolutely captured the original
animated character but she turned it
into something 100% different and just
ran all the way with it hell ran to the
moon with it she's so
over-the-top like who's a puppy code
just can't stop laughing at her she's a
rocket for what it is the film
is really not that bad it's 100%
serviceable I can't really see anyone
going into this movie being incredibly
disappointed I mean what do you think
you're going to see you're gonna see
Glenn Close over the top and you're
gonna see cute puppies that's it and as
that setup goes it's obvious they put a
lot of effort into it I think the only
people that would really want to see
them at are the same people that go see
Santa Paws but I give this movie credit
that it tries to be visually interesting
it tries to cast some good people it
tries to tell Allah the story through
silence which can be very difficult to
do so I guess I appreciate it more than
I actually like it I guess I like it a
little better than the anime version
it's just I didn't really even get into
the anime version that much I think it's
very simple if you really like dogs
especially Dalmatians you'll really like
this and yeah if you just want to see an
actress go batshit insane it's actually
kind of fun to watch for that - you're
looking for a fun little family film
with cute little animals that's not
gonna offend anybody
this definitely hits the spot
[Music]
when Ricky Ralph first came out the term
those being thrown around a lot is that
it was the Roger Rabbit of video game
movies and from the advertising it kind
of looked like that you saw kind of a
Donkey Kong ish knockoff suddenly in
with all these really famous characters
there's Bowser there's a bunch of street
fighter guys there's the ghost from
pac-man nothing like this has ever been
done in a movie at least not with video
games it really was the equivalent of
seeing Mickey Mouse and Bugs Bunny
together it was so surreal
however when Roger Rabbit a lot of these
characters keep popping up throughout
the entire film in this one it's only
the first couple minutes because of this
there was definitely crowd of people
that kind of fell ripped off I mean the
commercials they showed every scene that
had a video game character in it so when
you actually watch the film there's
practically nothing left I kind of like
those people want a little bit more of
them but the good news is the story and
characters were so good that you almost
don't notice much like Roger Rabbit the
story can completely hold up on its own
even if you didn't have those characters
in there
the main leads and ideas are more than
enough to keep it afloat the film starts
off in an arcade where there's an old
80's game called fix-it Felix the
villain of the game is wreck-it Ralph
kind of a Donkey Kong style character
that doesn't get much respect little do
we know there's a whole video game world
going on right under our noses
characters use the plugs and wires to
all meet up in one location to shoot the
talk nonsense all that good stuff
but Ralph's like a lot of video game
villains it's not feeling very loved
he's feeling underappreciated as the bad
guy of the game and what's more
attention for the important work that he
does so it starts game hopping to find
some way to get his reward the only
thing he can figure is that if he got a
medal somehow that would mean that he's
done a great deed so he travels into one
of the much more violent video games
gets his medal but loses it in another
one along the way he comes across a
glitch named Penelope who lives in kind
of a Mario Kart world where nobody likes
her either so they make a deal with one
another
if Ralph can help her get in the game
and get the appreciation she deserves
she'll help him get his medal back and
get him the appreciation he deserves but
there's an even bigger conspiracy going
on between villain side characters and
all sorts of craziness that might result
in the end of the video game world as we
know it I'm really impressed how even
though it's kind of a complicated story
when you get down to it they explain it
in a very simple way the film is very
good at throwing in different surprises
and turns around every corner in
explaining how the world works through
warp zones and cheat codes you can
actually change your identity and
anything about your environment really
the movie takes total advantage of
what's given to them it isn't just using
popular video game characters it's
totally embracing the idea of what they
have incorporating both the retro games
of the past and the newer games of today
throw the clever writing in satire
though there's also a very heartfelt
story between vanellope and ralph this
is the focus of the film and yeah I'd
like to seen a few more video game
characters this really is where the
attention should be the voice acting in
this is beyond pitch perfect I mean talk
about getting the best people to match
these characters john c reilly is the
big doofus who has a heart of gold Sarah
Silverman's the smart aleck little brat
Jane Lynch is the badass commander with
a backstory so funny I dare not ruin it
here the list goes on this is one of
those movies that does so well and
combining really great humor in with the
story that's telling they almost go hand
in hand
like something that's a pretty funny Joe
can also be a major plot device the
explanation about why Penelope has to be
kept out of the game is actually both
really funny and really heartbreaking
even though these are just video game
characters and you play them all the
time you really get wrapped up and what
they're going through you want to see
Ralph Guetta's metal you want to see
Penelope win the race you want to see
all sorts of good things happen to them
and overcome evil and all along the way
you're getting these great in jokes that
you don't need to know in order to
follow it but it just makes it all the
more enjoyable if you do I say my only
hang-up with the film is that we get a
little bit of that for scene where the
good guy has to be bad in order to not
hurt the other good guy and it's okay
not a misunderstanding or liar reveal
story but you know the drill just when
they're becoming the best of friends one
of them has to do something really mean
to hurt
the other one but it's also in order to
save them and honestly if it hadn't been
done a million times before it probably
would have worked fine here I mean they
do explain everything pretty well but
you just know after their little fight
and moping and doping around one of them
has to come to a realization and go back
and say they're sorry and that we can
begin the climax I know we need conflict
I know we need drama but we also need a
little variety and this has been done a
lot of times before the climax itself is
also a little mundane
I mean at first it's great starting off
with this race and people jumping on top
of other cars and stuff but then you go
into this fight on top of a mountain
with one of the characters turning into
a big monster and it's not awful it's
just again we've seen this a million
times and there isn't anything bad do to
it but honestly those are small gripes
Ricky Ralph has really likeable
characters a very clever setup and a
story environment that makes you realize
you don't need as much of the gimmicks
as you thought you would yeah it's neat
to see Zangief yeah it's neat that they
reference where a Croft but that's not
what the movies about nor should it be
what it's about it's about a connection
between these two polar opposites who
also have them to be Outsiders and so
they find a way to band together
oh well throwing in some really funny
side characters and some really great
humor you may not get as many classic
characters as you want but you'll
definitely get a whole bunch of new ones
better just as good
[Music]
you know it's funny when I saw Monsters
Inc the first thing I thought to myself
was yeah that was okay but I wonder what
they could do with the sequel I'm
assuming if you're watching this you
know how that first film ends so with
that ending you do kind of see a little
bit of possibility
what if boo did grow up what a sullivan
kept watching her
what did she became an adult who could
actually communicate with monsters or
maybe when she got to an age she didn't
believe in monsters anymore
maybe monsters would disappear maybe
it's something about losing childhood oh
my god this practically writes itself
but instead Pixar said it let's
just do a tease College movies
yeah because those to go so hand in hand
rather than being a sequel we have a
prequel showing how Mikan Solomon met up
for the first time and of course didn't
get along each one thinks they're gonna
be the great student at muster
University so naturally all sorts of
competition and comedic antics take
place but this menacing Dean decides she
doesn't like them yeah I don't entirely
know why she just kind of decides she
doesn't like them maybe because that's
what they do in a tease College movies I
don't know and speaking of which if
you've seen any 80s college movies I
need any friggin 80s College movies
you've seen monsters you it's not a
satire of 80s college films that would
be funny it's not doing anything
different with eighties college films
again that would be funny all it's doing
is taking the exact same characters
you've seen a million times and
replacing them with monsters the bully
jock the nerdy worm the stick-in-the-mud
Dean the quirky dorks the need to make
their frat house the greatest frat house
that there is and of course all these
people who don't get along trying to
find a way to get along in the end I
remember I saw the trailer for this I
thought it looked really stupid but I
also remember thing to myself its Pixar
Pixar the originators of these
incredible stories Finding Nemo of The
Incredibles the freakin Toy Story films
surely they wouldn't do something as
phoned-in as this but then I remembered
Cars 2 and got really depressed outside
of a few designs of some of the monsters
it's amazing the lack of originality
this film has
everything exists just to follow the
80's college movies tropes I remember
before seeing Muppets Most Wired they
had a short based on monsters view and
you know what it was a million times
more interesting they took advantage of
their environment and did something new
with it though he promised that was just
a few minutes long but this is an hour
and a friggin half it's easily one of
the most boring Pixar films I've ever
sat through you can predict every joke
you can predict every moment that's
gonna happen it's just it's why was this
deserving of so much time and effort to
go into it the only new thing that pops
up in this film is the ending and
without giving away too much it is
probably the only really good thing in
it it's kind of the idea that you don't
need to follow the traditional path that
everybody else does but it's done in a
way that's actually kind of clever and
probably hits close to home for a lot of
people in fact if I had to guess I would
assume this whole film was made just so
it could get this message across it's a
message you don't see much in movies and
especially in animated family films well
then I guess we have the Pixar
equivalent of Meet the Robinsons
something that has a really good message
but not the best means of displaying it
but he'll even Meet the Robinsons was so
strange and bizarre you could kind of
admire it for how odd it is this is more
like a textbook about how they made
animal house hell even watching a movie
about the making of animal house would
be more interesting than watching this
I've had a lot of fans upset with me
that I didn't like this film but I'm
sorry I just think it's awful I tried to
go in with a clear mind I tried to open
up to the idea that this could somehow
work but it just sucks out all the funny
all the originality all the interesting
characters all the neat story ideas for
such a stale experience I guess there's
nothing bad in it in terms of stuff that
be like offensive or unwatchable for
your kids but for anyone who's an adult
and has seen a tease College movies to
death and wants to move on to something
else this is a definite film to scare
you away
I can't describe the hate for the lone
ranger that surrounded it when it first
came out
even from the previews people were just
kind of rolling their eyes saying really
really I'm not gonna lie I kind of had
that reaction looking at the trailers
too but when the critics got hold of it
and the few people that actually want to
see it by God they just despised it they
said was overly long terribly written
horribly acted and just made no sense at
the time so I guess a large part of me
was really dreading having to review
this film but so many people have been
talking about it I guess it kind of made
sense to do so having finally seen it
are they right
well yeah but I don't know if I hate it
as much as everybody else does it is
definitely a bad movie and it is way too
long but a part of me does kind of say
if this came out 10 years ago say before
the Pirates of the Caribbean movies I
kind of wonder if it would have gotten a
warmer reception it might have been that
really bizarre distinct Western that's
never really been done in this way
before but because it did come out after
pipes of the Caribbean has even done by
the same people everyone just sort of
saw it as fone did pirates except in the
Old West
and yeah they're pretty much right I
guess a part of me does see a little bit
of possibility with Pirates in the Old
West though not much but a little the
story opens with Johnny Depp as the
famous Indian named Tonto he has a job
just standing around in a museum I don't
get it
but the makeups neat and he comes across
a boy who's interested in the story of
The Lone Ranger well since he was there
he tells the boy to sit back for two and
a half hours and listen to his origin
story The Lone Ranger was originally a
lawyer who had a very successful brother
who was a lawman one day after chasing
down an escaped convict both of them are
gunned down and even his brother's heart
is eaten by the villain isn't that long
but Otto is fascinated when the
spiritual Horace seems to pick on main
character to be brought back to life
Tonto doesn't believe them as he knows
he's an inexperienced to action hero but
the horse has made this choice so Tonto
decides to take him up as his partner
bring him back to the world of the
living and follow him to get justice
and/or revenge on the people who killed
him and his brother along the way they
come across all sorts of strange
characters colorful baddies and comedy
ranging from the goofy to the downright
grotesque I get the feeling a lot of the
worst parts were already kind of told to
me like the guy eating the heart or
Johnny Depp being in the museum for no
reason and some of the really stupid
jokes
so I guess expecting that going in I
paid a little bit more attention to the
stuff I actually kind of enjoyed I mean
okay it's over-the-top and silly but
that's kind of what I expected were the
Pirates of the Caribbean Western
everyone said giant Depp was just doing
Jack Sparrow as an Indian in this
version and yeah I see where they're
coming from but I don't know if I quite
see it as bad bad I still think he's a
good actor and yeah sort of the bug-eyed
and close lip thing is getting a little
old but he still kept my interest enough
now of course why he was chosen to play
a Native American when there's about a
million other actors therefore qualified
to do so I'm not sure well yeah I knew
he's a star buddy all that stuff I know
everyone says he's like 190th Native
American but how about somebody who's
like majority Native American when that
make a little bit more sense I mean we
eat does a good job being the
fish-out-of-water in this new territory
trying to follow the law while also
breaking it and being fairly charismatic
throughout most of it the villains are
mostly abour once again tying into some
sort of complicated plot about the
railroad and land ownership and oh who
cares we just want to see Cowboys be
Cowboys what it does do that it's kind
of neat in that it's really weird these
are very bizarre towns with very bizarre
people in them but a part of me kind of
likes that because I don't see that much
in westerns I was even kind of liking
the way they visually told the story
for example there's this woman with a
wooden leg who also wants revenge on the
same person even though her business
seems booming she says that Hebrew in
her career
literally all they do is show a picture
of her as a ballet dancer and you get it
know tons of dialog no big explanation
scenes it's just one picture and boom
you understand I like a movie that can
do that I only wish the rest of the
movie was like that at some point I
found myself getting really bored and I
looked on the DVD how long it was and we
were even at the halfway point yet good
God
why does Hollywood nowadays think that
if something has to be really big and
epic it has to be super long not every
movie needs to be lower the Rings not
every movie has to be lords of Arabia
the same thing happened with the Pirates
movie stop trying to be these gigantic
epics just be what you're supposed to be
be the friggin Lone Ranger cowboy
shooting having fun
let the epics be the epics and you be
something that's enjoyably mindless and
I know it's ironic me saying that seeing
how I did an anniversary film that was
three and a half hours long but that had
a lot of characters and to be fair this
is to two guys that were following for
an unbelievable amount of time I don't
care who you put in that role that's
gonna get boring after a while so yeah
is the movie good absolutely not is it
terrible
probably but a good chunk of that comes
from the timing if this was released
before the Pirates of the Caribbean
films I think it would have had a little
bit more of a chance and it would have
been seen as original and unique and
strange and dark and just a movie unlike
any other movie still having the
problems I said before with it being way
too long and such but I don't think it
would have gotten quite the extreme
hatred that it's getting today I'm glad
I saw parts of it I mean it was just so
creatively bizarre but what does any of
it have to do with the original idea of
the Lone Ranger and the Cowboys and the
Indians and just riding around and
having fun
not much this feels like Disney knew it
hit something big with the Pirates
franchise so they tried to have
lightning strike twice hell you could
argue even the Pyrus franchise it didn't
strike twice the result is a little too
much of what we've already seen before
and even then not done that great I
guess even ads worse this directors work
is just so strange died always find
something of bizarre value to it so I'm
not quite as pissed off as everybody
else was at it but yeah it's still bad
not the worst in my opinion but sadly
not worth checking out either
I kind of rolled my eyes when I heard
they were making a Maleficent movie I
mean it just seems like a pointless
thing to do
Maleficent is a great villain one of the
great villain she's so charismatic and
evil and loves every minute of it at his
elegant and clever and diabolical she's
given just the right amount of screen
time in the original seating so the idea
of learning more about her past didn't
seem too bright but at the same time I
was open to it I guess when the film
finally came out it became very obvious
what they were trying to do it's the
Wicked formula again trying to take a
fairy tale we all thought we knew and
tell it a different way where the bad
guy doesn't look so bad what I figured
that out which you can't very quickly in
this film it just sort of shrugged and
said whatever just give me some pleasing
eye candy it didn't I didn't think too
much of it but then later when I really
thought about it it's hard to piss me
off like really piss me off I thought
about what they were trying to do to one
of the great villains one of the great
Disney icons turning the mistress of all
evil into a simple case of
misunderstanding turning three of the
most likable comic relief's into these
idiotic morons turning an iconic Disney
fairy tale that has its flaws but was
still pretty damn creative into every
other poorly CG stale story that comes
out about fairy tales nowadays you know
what this movie really sucks a lot we
start off with the backstory of
Maleficent as a little girl who
apparently had wings originally okay
this is because she was a fairy all
right well she looked kind of cool so
we'll go with it she then meets a human
boy and they grow up falling in love but
then he finds out when he's older that
if he kills Maleficent he'll be given
unbelievable power but he can't quite do
that because he's too nice I guess so he
decides to cut off her wings instead she
decides from this day on that she hates
all humanity and is just gonna be evil
years later the King marries and
eventually has a daughter and you know
how this goes Maleficent comes to the
party curses the daughter and says when
she turns 16
prick her finger on a spinning wheel and
die once again the fairies are called in
to take her away and raise her but get a
load of this
Maleficent always knows where the baby
is and because the fairies are too
stupid to raise a child Maleficent
actually kind of raises her herself cuz
you know she's not so bad after all once
the child grows up she eventually bumps
into Prince Charming
they fall in love and all this time
Olympus and is not only watching but
actually getting on pretty good with her
because yeah this is what we want to see
one of the greatest villains of all time
having Girl Talk talking about feelings
chewing laughing having all sorts of fun
look am i watching it finally gets to a
point where Maleficent does and what the
friend says to die so she knocks out the
prince and tries to get them back
together because if she does fall in
love that pricks her finger maybe he can
wake her up and meanwhile the King has
gone crazy just because any vows to set
a trap for Maleficent yeah kind of a
shock he didn't do that before so it's a
battle between Maleficent the hero and
the princess's father the villain yeah I
can tell they really got the idea about
what Disney's Sleeping Beauty was all
about I won't give away what happens in
the end but remember what they did in
frozen with the true love thing and how
they did a little bit of a twist on it
yeah they do they here too except it was
already done in frozen so it's not
really a twist anymore I guess there's
one or two good things in this some of
the visuals are a little neat most of
them are pretty standard and not
rendered very well visually Jolie was
pretty cool as Maleficent she's got that
devilish smile and a cool look here or
there but while their acting is not
really bad it's not really anything that
great either the actor playing the King
is awful
I mean really bad I guess he's supposed
to be like this really complex character
but he just sort of has these weird mood
swings and out of nowhere goes nuts and
none of it's convincing and it all
sounds so silly they brought you back a
date you said I told those three idiots
lock it up you know do something about
his voice I can't explain it I don't
know if it's the inflections or the
pitch or whatever but he just annoys the
crap
she's only sleeping forever and
everything else like I said is trying to
turn this story into something it isn't
which okay wicked did something like
that and once upon a time did something
like that and they seemed to work out
okay but that's part of the problem they
already did it
if you're going to do it now you have to
add something really new or really
groundbreaking wicked have good writing
and characters and music outside the
fact that it was a twist on story we
already know this is just so standard
and not only that it takes characters
that you already loved and instead of
making them charming in a new way it
just sucks out anything that made them
unique
the fairies good god I mean there's dumb
and then there's just insultingly dump
it's almost like the writer of this
movie just didn't like the person who
created the fairies originally or
something and just really wanted to
stick it to them I mean they are just so
terribly written I know this is done so
that Maleficent looks more like the star
but come on this is downright degrading
and like I said
Maleficent herself is just not that
interesting I guess this could be kind
of a neat spin seeing how we all know
the story and yeah it is kind of juicy
with her getting her wings chopped off
and hating all humanity and stuff and
trying to go through a change but nobody
is written with any charm or charisma I
give the actors credit that they're
trying to add charm and charisma but
there's just so little to work off of
nothing about a cries that somebody had
this great idea and really want to tell
this story in a brand new way that was
gonna just change the way you look at
everything it's obviously just trying to
do what everybody else is doing and in
the process it insults some of our
greatest Disney characters the fairies
were awesome don't try to make them
stupid
well episode was great don't try to make
her good the Kings were charming don't
try to make them this asshole I don't
know if you want more reasons why I hate
it go watch the honest trailers of it I
guess if you're just looking for
something that's kind of pretty a touch
create that they remind you a little bit
of those classic fairy tales then it's a
harmless waste of time well if you're
looking for something that's gonna suck
you in and you can't wait what's gonna
happen next and it's very psychological
and intriguing and
I don't know anything not stale and
hasn't been done a million times then
you can definitely give this one a pass
[Music]
it's Disney's runaway hit frozen just a
little over a year since it came out and
people still won't shut up about this
movie it's a cultural phenomenon I have
not seen an anime film from Disney get
this much attention since Lion King
everybody's still singing the songs
everybody's still quoting the lines
everybody's still selling the
merchandise it's just a monster like
probably most of you I kind of agree
it's all over the place and most likely
overplayed but I'm not gonna lie I'm one
of those people that loves it just as
much as anyone else the story is about
two princesses named Elsa and Anna Elsa
has a curse where she can control the
cold she can make it snow shoot ice beam
create snowmen all sorts of craziness
but one night as a little kid she
accidentally almost kills her sister her
mom and dad take them to a group of Rock
gnomes who say that they can save her
but they had to keep the power a secret
so they Arisa Anna's memory and decide
that it's best to keep them as far apart
as possible in hopes that our power
won't hurt her anymore
years go by and after the parents
tragically die the two of them grow up
into polar opposites
Elsa not surprisingly is an awkward
introvert and Anna is a social butterfly
ready to open up to anybody on the day
of Elsa's coronation as Queen Anna
accidentally reveals Elsa's powers to
everybody causing Elsa to run away and
leave the entire kingdom in ice so it's
up to Anna to find her sister and
convince her to come back and stop all
this winter along her way she comes
across a climber named Kristoff a
magical snowman named Olaf and all sorts
of crazy adventures trying to not only
save the kingdom but her sister as well
there are so many things to talk about
with this movie it's hard to know where
to even start probably the thing I'm
impressed with most is their ability to
break certain cliches while still
holding true to others that make Disney
so popular but they do it in a way
that's not so obvious it feels very
natural in the way they set up these
characters I thought back to films like
Enchanted where they just hammered the
lesson in that there
going against these Disney cliches and
here it just felt like it was part of a
story they would tell even if it wasn't
Disney related because it ties in to
what's going on nowadays and will
continue to happen in the future for
example there is still a romance that
blooms in only a few days but they also
Mock the fact that she's going to marry
somebody that she just met which of
course is a big criticism the female
leads in the past but this also makes
sense for the character she has been
shut away for so long that she would
just give herself to anybody it's a new
experience and she would be excited but
this movie is showing the dangers of it
in fact originally I was kind of against
the idea that they were sort of a
last-minute villain thrown in but
without giving away too much this once
again shows a really good lesson the
surprise reveal shows the danger of
being too trusting to anybody which is
not only a good lesson for kids but a
really good lesson for kids nowadays
with the social media and everybody on
it so often both Anna and Elsa are
perfect extremes to learn something from
Elsa is an introvert who wants to stay
away from people much like how some
people can just be glued to their
computers and phones and not go outside
that much people need to know how to
socially interact if they're going to
survive but anna has the opposite
problem if you reveal too much about
yourself and will just give your heart
to anybody again like a lot of people on
the social media do there can be a
downside to that as well the characters
are also likable not only do we have two
princesses in this but one of them moves
on the Queen isn't evil is actually
really respectable and smart and the
other isn't so dainty and basic she's
really really funny they don't mind if
they make her a little bit of a ditzy er
there because it's totally explained why
the situation totally backs up why she
would be this way but at the same time
she's very likable you love her passion
and there is something so nice knowing
that the majority of the humor that
comes from this movie comes from the
main characters and not all just in
comic relief the main characters can be
funny and goofy but with that said even
the obvious comic relief they do bring
in isn't really that bad I don't think
Olaf is a hilarious character but I got
a laugh out of him once in a while and
he wasn't annoying where most Disney
sidekicks get a lot of their humor from
yelling and being loud this one actually
whispers a lot of his jokes I haven't
really seen that in a Disney fairy tale
and it's actually really effect
funny the music what can I say you're
all still humming these tunes let it go
you want to build a snowman for the
first time in forever I remember when I
was first talking about these
songwriters in the Winnie the Pooh movie
and I said I so want them to go on to
something cuz these are such great songs
holy did they get rewarded for
their talents people are still singing
these songs they're releasing it in
theaters with little sing-along lyrics
at the bottom it's just insane how
popular they are and what I love about
too is that the songs helped the movie
and tell the story that's what the
Disney musicals did they didn't just say
let's get a pop star like Elton John to
write five songs that honestly if you
took them out you wouldn't miss that
much in terms of story or someone like
Phil Collins who just sort of sings in
the background that you could have just
replaced with orchestral music and
nothing would change whatsoever these
are songs that actually explain what the
characters are going through and move
the story forward and they're done
fantastically I know I did in this - a
Craig video criticizing the fact that
it's played all over the place and yeah
it is I'm not gonna act like it isn't we
are over playing it I'm sure it's
driving most people insane but the sad
truth is I'm one of those obnoxious
people who plays it over and over that
doesn't mean I won't make fun of it but
yeah I'm one of those morons who does it
but to be fair I only listen to it in my
car without any kids to play it for
actually does sound a really pathetic
but I don't care I love the music that
much the film is also gorgeous looking I
could almost see people whipping this
out around every Christmas look at the
way they shoot winter look at the colors
look at the angles look at the
landscapes I could get lost in this
winter I want to live in this winter
which I know I kind of do but this one
looks nicer if I did have a problem with
anything I would say that the back story
is really rushed I know for some people
those elements can really turn them off
as I've heard their major criticisms
like why they did do this to the two
little girls and shouldn't have grown
them up this way and so on so forth and
I get it it is kind of a plot hole and
in the development of our main
characters that sort of causes all this
but personally I give it a little bit of
a leeway because I say that's kind of a
fairy tale element sort of like how is
Luke Skywalker firing one torpedo gonna
blow up the entire Death Star or how is
the Joker took down the batplane with
one bullet from his gun it's one of
those treat of liberties that for me is
worth going through to get to the best
parts of the story with that said frozen
is one of my top ten favorite Disney
films he'll maybe even top five it
brought me right back into that feeling
that I was seeing something big and
grand and Disney and on top of that it
was a fairy tale when's the last time
you saw a traditional fairy tale take
the world by storm I don't mean
something like tangle that was a hit or
once upon a time that's doing well I
mean like take over the world it's been
a while but it's great to see again and
yeah like I said it is probably being
exploited a little too much and all over
the place but hell I much rather have
kids and adults rewatch this than stay
transformers a twilight this one has so
much more creativity and intelligence to
it and music and visuals and characters
and just I'm just gushing all over it
again it's one of the few films I can
just proclaim as an instant classic a
film you can guarantee years from now
millions of people are still gonna be
watching and sharing with their kids
hell with other adults I'd say go check
it out but who the hell hasn't just go
watch it again I know I'm going to and
have a hell of a lot of fun doing it
[Music]
it only figures to celebrate Christmas
Day with a Christmas movie and the
Muppet Christmas Carol seems to be a
good one to talk about it's so
interesting that for so many younger
people this is their introduction to the
classic Charles Dickens tale
I shouldn't see that as a bad thing
seeing how the Mickey Christmas Carol
was my introduction to it and truth be
told it's not a bad way to be introduced
is it the best way no but I think it's
still pretty reasonably well done
Lebanese our Scrooge played by Michael
Caine is the town's most hated man one
of his workers Bob Cratchit played by
Kermit the Frog and yes I know somebody
else please come at the Frog but come on
work with me here tries to get Christmas
day off to spend with his family after
Scrooge begrudgingly agrees he's told
that he's going to be haunted by three
ghosts that night the ghost of Christmas
past present and future each one shows
him exactly that the past president
future and slowly over the course of the
film Scrooge starts to realise the
importance of Christmas the importance
of being nice and the importance of
sharing his wealth with puppets half his
size the film is pretty by-the-book and
following the original story they have
gonzo and Rizzo as the narrators who
constantly get beaten up throughout the
entire movie and all the other Muppet
characters play the parts that we know
from the book the one that actually has
me pissing my pants with laughter is
fozziwig by God I swear this whole movie
was put together just so they could do
that pun on the whole it's a decent film
especially when you look at the sets and
the atmosphere and the colors it's clear
the focus of the movie was not to tell a
great Muppet film but rather a decent
Christmas carol now the downside is some
might find that as a turn off as someone
who loves the Muppet movie and the
Muppet Caper in their early films I
really thought there was going to be a
lot more humour to this like if you saw
the Muppets do a Christmas carol on say
The Muppet Show you know everything
would go wrong their personalities will
get in the way and be all crazy and
stuff will be blowing up and falling
apart but here it's got to be done more
seriously which isn't a bad thing I
guess it just doesn't feel that Muppet
is half the time
but even that's made up for when they do
something actually a little different
from the story stuff that maybe other
versions should consider put again one
of my favorite additions is that the
ghost of Christmas present has a bad
memory why because he's always living in
the present
so sometimes he'll repeat things like
he'll introduce himself twice or say his
sentence he already said that's a really
clever idea I also love the design of
the ghost of Christmas past that's kind
of a baby but kind of an adult too is
sort of ageless but there are definitely
some moments there are by no means
terrible but can definitely be a little
awkward well the songs for the most part
are pretty damn good some of them almost
sound a little too cleaned up
like the love is gone is sunk almost a
little too nice you almost miss the
emotion of it and let's get to the part
that's really gonna make you want to
kill me I don't think Michael Caine is
that greatest group you heard right I
don't think he's awful but there are
just so many moments where I feel like
he's really just phoning it in for
example what the is this it just
cracks me up how weird it is there's
also some line deliveries that just feel
lazy to me if I look at this scene we
just sort of calls Bob Cratchit's name
and it just sounds like really bad
acting mr. Scrooge Bob Bob Cratchit does
anyone else feel that was just kind of
half-assed but the biggest scene and I
mean quite literally the biggest scene
is when he's supposed to break down and
change his ways there's no big music
there's no big visuals for it it all
just relies on his performance and I'm
sorry it doesn't deliver I don't feel a
thing for this guy present in the future
I don't entirely blame him as the
staging and pacing in the scene is kind
of weird too but I think of all the
other Scrooge's and how I felt so bad
for them and they just made this such a
huge scene and here it's just a guy who
looks like he's trying to be sad while
saying some lines but with all that
I'd say only about half of the
performance is not very good there
actually is a half that's pretty decent
and strangely enough a lot of it's in
the musical numbers Michael Caine is not
a very good singer but he actually does
put a lot of passion when he's doing the
singing roles he actually does feel very
jubilant wasting in the final song and I
really love the addition of having him
sing a duet with the version of his past
love that's a great idea and he does it
very well he also has the threatening
look and stamina of a proper Scrooge so
I can't say he's terrible because when
he does something good it is good but
for me it's only about half the
performance I don't know it could very
well be that I love Christmas carols so
much and I love the character of Scrooge
that I really really hold them to a high
standard in fact honestly I can probably
count on my one hand how many great
Scrooge's I think that really are that
I've seen but still that's not what
you're coming to see you're coming to
see the Muppets and the Muppets do fine
even though I don't feel like it's a
traditional Muppet movie I do kind of
give it credit that it tried to do
something really serious they still
address a lot of the dark stuff they
still kill off Tiny Tim this could so
easily be awkward and laughably done but
it's actually pretty legit and yeah like
a lot of people I watch it every year
too it's a strange combo but a decent
one the kids will enjoy the puppets the
adults will enjoy the jokes and the
Christmas lovers will enjoy Christmas
have a wonderful holiday and possibly
pop this film in
[Music]
ever since the movie came out everyone's
been telling me you gotta see big hero
six you gotta see big hero six all the
critics loved it all the audience's
loved it then the number one movie for a
couple weeks it's just incredible oh my
god
big hero six naturally I got
pretty excited to see Disney do kind of
a superhero film as well I really
thought about it I don't think we've
actually seen one from them
I mean we've definitely seen heroes in
their movies but not as much comic-book
characters I paid my ticket went on in
and let me tell you I have never felt an
overwhelming sensation that a film was
100% okay it's honestly hard to think of
what else to even say about it it's okay
how's the fighting it's okay
how are the characters they're okay how
are the visuals they're okay to be
honest I'm really dumbfounded why so
many people are talking about this film
it's not bad it's not good it's just
okay it's about the most standard
superhero film I've seen in a while not
that it has nothing new it's just all
the new stuff is okay the film takes
place in the future with a boy named
Hiro Hiro is a boy genius who has an
older brother who's also a boy genius
but Hiro is also walking that thin line
of applying himself to do great things
or just using it to benefit himself so
his brother introduces him to a team of
other super geniuses and he decides he
wants to be a part of it but again to
the school that they're all in he has to
win this competition sure enough he
comes up with an invention that wins
everybody's eye but loses everything in
a fire including his brother a long time
later he comes across one of his
brothers inventions named baymax baymax
is kind of like a one robot Hospital
he's designed to help people who are in
physical or even mental pain but sure
enough Hiro sees an opportunity to put
this machine to good use when he sees
there's a masked villain who's using his
invention for evil it's up to Hiro
baymax and his newfound team of geniuses
to not only find out what's going on but
to do it as what else a super team
not gonna lie literally I predicted who
was gonna die who was gonna be the
villain and even how the movie was gonna
end I wouldn't usually mind as it's more
part of the journey but this movie
seemed really bent on surprising us with
its twist as well as its comedy and both
were unbelievably predictable it was
really strange to see all these
characters that seem to be designed well
but I felt like I've seen them in a
million other projects
you got the stoner loser you got the
hyper geek you got the cool one who
chews the bubblegum and most of their
dialogue is just centered around the
fact that they're making catchphrases
that they're gonna repeat later and when
they do it is so Forrest and don't get
me wrong I know a lot of these superhero
stories have a lot of that traditional
manipulation saying catchphrases
defeating supervillains all that good
stuff but superhero films have come a
long way recently movies like Batman The
Dark Knight and of course all the
incredible Marvel movies are coming out
now which ironically this is a part of
our light-years beyond what this movie
is trying to do the only thing that
sticks out about it at all which I guess
is kind of traditional Disney is the
relationship between Hiro and baymax
it's cute simple that never seems to go
to forest
baymax seems to keep to his exact
programming yet we still feel something
for it's not like he breaks it and says
he wants to be human or something he
just stays the exact being that he's
supposed to be the best parts of the
movie are with him trying to help Hiro
deal with his loss when the movie focus
is on that element it's good but when it
tries to actually be a superhero film
it's kind of dull it's not like there's
no imagination put into it it's just
imagination I've seen in a million other
places it's not like I didn't see
characters I just kind of saw characters
that were ten years behind the curve but
like I said I can't think of anything
that was awful it was just kind of
predictable and kind of been done before
like a lot even San Fran Tokyo what an
idea combining these two cities together
what I mean
look at it it's creative it's not lazy
or anything but doesn't it also can't
look like a million other futuristic
cities you've seen before with a million
other characters you've kind of already
seen before maybe if they kept it more
simple just focusing on the boy in the
robot I would have enjoyed it a lot more
as is it's just all right
nothing terrible nothing spectacular
just alright but maybe that's not what
you'll think maybe you'll go and see it
a spectacular like the majority of
people do fair enough there's nothing
really that bad in it maybe I'm just not
the right person who can see the
greatness in it if you're really curious
check it out for yourself
[Music]
okay so I'm going a little out of order
on this one but at the same time I
couldn't get into into the woods in time
to do a Disney assembler for it and yeah
I'll just do it by popular demand in
January but until then let's do one I
actually have gotten a lot of requests
to do The Brave Little Toaster a film a
million times better than its deserving
to be I mean just listen to that title
The Brave Little Toaster this sounds
like a story for one year olds that
should have little to no effort put into
it and even the set up in some respects
is kind of like that to a bunch of
appliances with eyes mouths the whole
thing had been sitting around the house
waiting for their master to return but a
long amount of time has passed and is
starting to feel like he's never going
to come back fearing he might be in
trouble they decide to leave the home
and go looking for him the rest of the
film is the great big journey they take
to try and find where he's gone
our characters include a radio played by
Jon Lovitz a vacuum an electric blanket
a lamp and of course our Brave Little
Toaster for a setup that sounds almost
insultingly simple it's really kind of
surprising how much effort they put into
it there's a lot of quieter moments in
this movie which when I saw is a little
kid I was really impressed by it kind of
made me feel more adult to watch
something that wasn't constantly trying
to be loud and singing and obnoxious it
can let softer moments just be softer
moments oh that's it there's definitely
a lot of craziness at two they come
across a lot of neat characters a lot of
wonderful designs a lot of scary designs
and even a few hummable musical moments
I especially loved the garbage dump song
it has a really good beat to it it even
years later I once in awhile catch
myself humming it
one of the fun things about that you
know I would enjoy is that there's a lot
of scary scenes in it yeah for something
called The Brave Little Toaster there's
a lot of really creepy intense moments
look at this climax this is pretty
hardcore for a little kids film
[Music]
but even beyond that the characters are
actually kind of enjoyable they're all
really simple but really unique and
distinct they all kind of come together
and help each other out as a group and
they all have their moments to shine I
really appreciate this film not just for
being enjoyable but for taking an idea
that pretty much had nothing going for
it and just putting their damnedest into
it this is not a lazy project this is
something that people came together said
you know what this is weird this is odd
but we're gonna do everything that we
can with it it's a good film okay not
phenomenal but I don't know what kind of
phenomenal things you can really do with
this set up hell I'm amazed they even
made it to okay standards this is a fun
little adventure to take your kids on it
has enough colorful songs and characters
to keep them interested and enough scary
moments to get them going ooh what's
gonna happen next it's not spectacular
but there's just something to the
atmosphere I really like about it every
action they make you feel the
consequences of and you're totally
rooting for them every step of the way
with a helmet I thought toasters would
leave such interesting lives
[Applause]
[Music]
by popular demand it's into the woods
the famous Stephen Sondheim musical
actually saw this play in the theater
appreciation class once I remember
thinking wow this is incredibly clever
and really smart but it's kind of not
really my thing
I knew the music was great and in many
respects it was ahead of its time
throwing these twists on fairytales that
now seem to be everywhere but it's not
something I listen to over and over and
over however I also never thought they
would make a movie out of it because
well it's one of the hardest adaptations
you can do on top of so many characters
there's a bunch of different tones and a
lot of uncomfortable adult themes and a
lot of dark elements that really
wouldn't mix well with the movie-going
audience that's looking more for a
musical comedy in this kind of setup
does it pay off well let's look at the
story or stories I should say it's
pretty much all of the classic fairy
tale characters we'll be riding hood
Jack in the Beanstalk Cinderella and so
forth every one of them starts off
wishing for something greater than what
they have Cinderella wants to go to the
ball Rapunzel wants to be free so on and
so forth a good chunk of the focus is on
the baker and his wife who just want to
have a child but a crazy witch played by
Meryl Streep comes in and lets them know
that the reason she can't have a child
is because she cursed them because of a
terrible act the Baker's father did
years ago in order to relieve the curse
they have to get all sorts of various
items that tie into the other fairy tale
characters and in a very short amount of
time everybody's running around singing
songs trying to get their goals done and
when everything seems resolved and fixed
it turns out we're only at the halfway
point suddenly all they're achieved
goals and happily ever after as it turns
out isn't what they were looking for or
didn't turn out like they expected thus
the second half of the movie is actually
trying to pick up the problems of the
original problems that they had in the
first half kind of a strange story
layout for a movie huh especially one
that's based on a two-and-a-half-hour
musical and that is the film's biggest
problem this is obviously meant for our
Broadway crowd with a Broadway audience
you know there's gonna be an
intermission so when you get to the
halfway point it looks like everyone's
gonna live happily ever after
it's really funny to hear the narrator
say end of part 1 with a movie however
you're thinking it's really going to end
and you're gonna go home soon and now
you're sort of disappointed where you
find out there's at least 45 minutes
left and remember at that point a lot of
people were checking their watches
saying good lord how long is this movie
and the irony is I actually liked the
second half more than the first half
despite the fact that they cut a lot out
but again I can see why it's a movie
going audience and this is really tough
to keep people's attention when it's set
up like this this either needed an
intermission or needed to be two movies
and honestly I can't see that happening
in this day and age not with into the
woods well also the actors are good
including Meryl Streep who's really
yucking it up she reminds me of Glenn
Close from 101 Dalmatians but it still
has those softer moments too
the tone is all over the place things
that the original show had settle or
suddenly made extreme and things that
the show had extreme are suddenly made
subtle and sometimes they work sometimes
they don't but to be honest even in the
Broadway play it was kind of hard to get
a feel for it the original show had
really goofy stuff like at some point
they feed the narrator to a giant that's
really funny but then at other points
some main characters die off and in
really tragic ways and they sing these
really sad songs about it's like wait a
minute didn't we just get rid of the
narrator a second ago breaking the
fourth wall how do these two things mix
back then I was very new and
experimental for Broadway especially
considering the original fairy tales but
in a film this is really hard to
transfer over in fact a lot of the
comedy is sucked out to replace it with
a lot of really heavy adult elements
like abandonment issues adultery
separation anxiety mommy and daddy
issues death of a pet death of a family
member death of a friend
responsibilities of husband and wife
don't get me wrong the original musicals
are had these undertones with the big
bad wolf and Little Red Riding Hood but
good guy Johnny Depp in this version
they take those undertones and turn it
into holy in your face how could
this be mistaken for anything else
overtones even the song Red Riding Hood
sings to the hunter afterwards I now
hear in a totally different way and it's
really uncomfortable on the one hand I
give them credit that they went full
force and just did it but yeah this is
weird
so hearing all this you probably think I
really don't like the movie and yeah
the whole I don't think it works and
dink why come together but at the same
time it is such a tough adaptation and
as someone who did find the show
interesting I don't regret seeing it
because I wanted to see how they were
gonna try and do a lot of this and some
of the choices are very clever I really
like the visuals when you see Red Riding
Hood and the grandma and the wolf's
stomach that was really creative I love
the way the atmosphere really captures
the characters emotions in the second
half just strange because the first half
that has all the Giants of running
around and fantasy stuff is actually
played very safe not that much grand
creativity it's mostly just done in
medium shots but even then some things
that work like every mare there's a song
where Cinderella's trying to think about
what to do and they actually freeze time
that was a cool effect
there's another great shot when giant
Depp howls like a wolf and we get this
cool silhouette I really wanted more of
those but for the couple that we got it
wasn't that bad the real star of the
movie is the music I think that is one
of the advantages to the film being so
straightforward in the way it's shot is
that it allows the music to really excel
you're not really being distracted by
all these crazy visuals being thrown at
you you're constantly listening to the
nice melodies and the clever lyrics and
like I said even though the second half
has a lot of the songs cut out they
still sound pretty nice I was really
shocked at how well Meryl Streep did
with some of the slower songs I know she
doesn't always get the pitch or the
notes right but I thought she sold it
okay in between all the other goofy
scenes she has indoors so what I
recommend it
only if you're curious to see how the
Broadway show is adapted because it is
need to check out if you're curious
about the choices they make or what they
leave in or take away it's neat to see
as an experiment but if you're looking
for a completed work that masterfully
mixes the complex with the simple this
doesn't quite balance out I'm glad I saw
it but more just to see how they did it
it's by no means awful and I appreciate
a lot of what they tried to do and I'm
happy at the moments when it really did
succeed but it's definitely a mess and
to its credit I don't know how I would
fix it do you cut out more do you add
more do you make it more visually
interesting or do you play it down even
more so the music shines it's all over I
don't know this musical ever can
properly be turned into a good film but
it was a valiant attempt and sometimes I
don't mind checking those out if you're
in the right mood or just a little
curious give it a chance and see their
best
[Music]
you